hey guys it's the 7th of sep tember and
we have so many announcements to get to
but first i wanted to talk to you about
the fact that it's are you okay date in
australia today it aims to raise
awareness of mental health issues and
encourages you to check in with your
friends and family to see how they're
doing under the video games first up it
seems like a final fantasy blu-ray movie
collection could be on its way amazon
has listed a collection featuring final
fantasy 7 Advent Children final fantasy
the spirits within and Kingsley Final
Fantasy 15 the product page does not
include a release date or price but the
description reads all the final fantasy
movies now together in a single
collection experience the adventure
fantasy and action-packed battles
surrounding various heroes against evil
at a unique to the best-selling final
fantasy video game franchise the
description then focuses on the upcoming
Kingsley film amazon also has two
listings for final fantasy 7 advent
children complete and final fantasy the
spirits within a four standalone blu-ray
releases on october for no official word
from square enix on this one as yet but
as they are still talking about those
fallout 4 mods that are yet to go into
the ps4 the mod program was supposed to
be out in June and now it's very much
not June and still no PS 4 mods news
website Metro asked Bethesda marketing
exec Pete Hines to expand on what
exactly went wrong there to which he
replied all I can say is that the
fallout 4 ps4 mod program is undergoing
and evaluation process and as soon as
it's done and we have more info we're
going to let everyone know adding it's
definitely not that we've decided not to
do it we absolutely positively want to
get ps4 mods out as fast as humanly
possible cloth for mugs have been on
Xbox one since May elsewhere in the
interview Hines taste that it's likely
but they still will have another III
showcase next year finally the moment
you've probably been waiting for sony
announced today that there are two new
ps4 models coming your way the first is
the ps4 slim it's thirty percent smaller
than the original model significantly
lighter uses 28 to 34
less power and includes a 500 gigabyte
hard drive as you'd expect this is going
to be the standard ps4 going forward and
it'll be out in most markets on sep
tember 15 the 299 bucks yep just a week
from today for those after a little more
power sony also unveiled the playstation
core pro which will launch on remember
10 of this year and run you three
hundred and ninety-nine bucks intended
to complement the standard ps4 the new
box has a one terabyte hard drive double
GPU power technology adapted from AMD
polaris graphical architecture a better
cpu clock speed and a new pokey algae
bit in the middle the bro will support
4k gaming and HDR but does not include a
4k blu-ray drive lead architect mark
cerny showed off a bunch of games
running in 4k and HDR and added the
patches are on their way to over half a
dozen Sony titles to take advantage of
ps4 pro activision then confirmed that
both call of duty infinite warfare and
modern warfare remastered would support
the new capabilities of the ps4 pro as
well as black ops 3 EI followed up by
pledging fee for 17 battlefield 1 and
Mass Effect Andromeda to the new console
and we got to see Andromeda gameplay
running in 4k yes that is indeed a
jetpack Netflix and YouTube are also
releasing new apps to support 4k
streaming you can check out the full
list of hardware specs in our story on
site let me know what you think of the
new consoles down in that comment
section and be sure to head to gamespot
we've got stories on hulu both and
pokemon go I will see you again tomorrow
you